los habitantes de bojayá un pueblo
ubicado en la selva del departamento
colombiano del chocó conmemoran hoy
lunes 2 de mayo los 20 años de una de
las masacres más cruentas del conflicto
armado en la que murieron unas siempre
son así decenas resultaron heridas la
matanza ocurrió un día como hoy del año
2002 cuando la guerrilla de las farc
lanzó un cilindro-bomba contra los
paramilitares las autodefensas ünidas de
colombia
pero el explosivo cayó en la iglesia
donde se habían refugiado parte de este
pueblo hecho que causó mucho dolor y que
los habitantes de esta localidad temen
que se repite es que la violencia
persiste en esta remota localidad en la
que hacen presencia también la guerrilla
del ejército de liberación nacional
hablamos del ln y los paramilitares
autodefensas gaitanistas de colombia
conocidas también como el clan del golfo
ahora este hecho pasa a la jurisdicción
especial para la paz que busca reparar a
las víctimas y conocer
de lo que realmente ocurrió aquel día
para ello entonces saludamos a nuestro
primer invitado luis eduardo celis
analista de seguridad y paz en colombia'
luis eduardo buen día feliz de un es
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de frança 24 cuál es el
paso de este hecho en la historia de
colombia y dentro del conflicto armado
cual es importancia lo que ocurrió allí
en bojayá
bueno un buen día para toda la audiencia
de france 24 y muchas gracias por
recolocar los temas de colombia en la
agenda pues se moja ya es uno es uno más
de los miles de hechos gravísimos en
este largo conflicto y cuando digo miles
no estoy exagerando que realmente en
este conflicto de más de 60 años
pues están documentados las cifras son
enormes no más de 230 mil homicidios más
de cuatro mil masacres más de 30 mil
secuestros entonces pues así cada
indicador muestra el horror de esta
larga confrontación y luego -ha ya pues
es un hecho gravísimo pues como todos
los hechos que vulneran la dignidad
humana los derechos de las personas de
los derechos de las comunidades
bojayá también muestra en lo que es la
incapacidad de un estado para para
llevar adelante una confrontación de
manera correcta porque los hechos de
bojayá o sea el hecho de que se estaban
enfrentando
los paramilitares y las farc fue fue
pleno conocimiento de la fuerza pública
la fuerza pública sabía los movimientos
de uno y otro contrincante y no hizo
nada para proteger a la población está
bien yo creo que aquí hay
responsabilidad de las farc hay
responsabilidad de los paramilitares y
también hay responsabilidad del estado
colombiano de provisión como en muchos
casos de manera correcta ahora luís
eduardo que se sabe hasta ahora
realmente sobre lo que ocurrió ahí en
esta masacre tan dolorosa para el pueblo
de chocó y por supuesto también para
colombia y también le pregunto para para
nuestra audiencia internacional que pues
no puede conocer muy bien lo que ocurre
en el choco porque este departamento en
el pacífico colombiano sufre de tanta
violencia y porque tampoco el estado ha
sido capaz durante todos estos años del
conflicto armado y ya como decimos a 20
años de que pasó esta masacre porque no
pone cartas en el asunto y pues trata de
resolver este tema de seguridad tan
grave en el departamento del chocó
bueno los hechos del choco están
documentados para las personas
interesadas pueden consultar en los
informes del centro nacional de memoria
histórica que con el liderazgo de
gonzalo sánchez hizo un trabajo muy
juicioso de documentación pero palabras
más para vendernos un enfrentamiento de
los paramilitares con las farc y en ese
enfrentamiento la pobla en una pequeña
población
afro sobre el río atrato en medio del
enfrentamiento de la población se
refugió una buena parte de la población
se refugió en la iglesia y un cilindro
bomba artesanal lanzado por las farc
cayó sobre la iglesia y vino la tragedia
no sea no más de 80 muertos más de 100
heridos en muchos niños muchas mujeres
entonces eso es lo que hoy se conmemora
en la en estos 20 años de tragedia si
sobre los hechos del pacífico' fuese
el pacífico fue la última zona donde
llegó el conflicto colombiano el
conflicto armado colombiano arrancó en
la zona andina se prepara la orinoquía
se fueron la amazonía y la última zona a
la que llegó en los años 90 con mayor
intensidad fue en el pacífico colombiano
hasta el día de hoy y pues muestra la
incapacidad del estado colombiano para
tener un control del territorio muestra
la persistencia del narcotráfico como un
tema que no se puede controlar con esas
políticas de guerra y de fuerza
solamente sino que se requieren temas
mucho más complejos del desarrollo
regional de la partición de las
comunidades y superar una guerra
fracasada pero como tú lo dijiste hasta
el día de hoy la población de bojayá y
la población del pacífico sufren de la
violencia que el estado colombiano no
puede controlar
louis porque también esta cifra de
muertos varía porque hasta el día de hoy
no se sabe con exactitud cuál es
realmente la cifra de muertos se habla
de 80 89 ciento 219 porque todavía
después de 20 años no sabemos
exactamente cuántas personas aparecieron
en ese lugar
bueno las las cifras que varían pues
pueden tener varias explicaciones la
falta de rigor en la en las
instituciones colombianas para
documentar el hecho de que son
violencias que se han dado en zonas muy
alejadas y la documentación ha sido muy
difícil en las primeras horas para
documentar con claridad los hechos
pero en cualquier cifra es un horror que
este mencionaron y claro que tiene razón
en el tema de las cifras es un tema que
hay que basar en está en este esfuerzo
de planificación luis eduardo cree que
esta cifra a lo mejor se puede arreglar
se puede aclarar cuando este caso ahora
va a pasar a la justicia especial para
reparar recordemos que ese organismo se
creó tras los acuerdos de paz firmados
en el 2016 entre el gobierno el entonces
presidente juan manuel santos y la ex
guerrilla de la farc que se busca
realmente en esta instancia finalmente
se puede conocer lo que realmente pasó
digamos los temas de
comprensión y de conocimiento de lo que
pasó en bojayá yo creo que están
bastante bien documentados o sea como
como le dije al principio si hay
informes del centro del amor histórica
que relatan desde la voz de los
protagonistas de la que supieron desde
la comunidad lo que pasó hoy y una
investigación muy juiciosa
lo que falta son las sanciones como solo
como los responsables son en parte son
las farc porque también estos
responsables también hay una
responsabilidad los paramilitares
también hay responsabilidad por omisión
o por acción estaría por establecer de
la fuerza pública colombiana que no
protegió a las comunidades siendo que
había alertas con suficiente tiempo de
lo que estaba pasando en esa región
en ese marco por lo que lo que le
corresponde a la justicia es sancionar a
los responsables y en este caso pues el
tribunal
y tiene esa responsabilidad es el
tribunal de la jurisdicción especial de
paz es el tribunal especial que se
conformó en el acuerdo con las farc y el
estado colombiano entonces van a haber
sanciones por supuesto que si van a
haber sanciones y eso es lo que tendrá
que establecer el tribunal de la gente